it seems completely incredible at 21
years ago tonight our next guest took
home the first Oscar given for the best
achievement in Direction since that time
he is continued as one of our top will
be makers and that picture so long ago
has become a milestone a great tradition
it won't be a $64 answer when I tell you
that the picture was seventh heaven and
of course I am introducing to you mr.
Frank Bozek
Frank how are you so well preserved -
you know I was a child prodigy - bah
I remember 21 years ago how my Nisha
when I first received that I can imagine
there are other knees here shaking this
minute my hope is that 21 years from now
other hopefuls will be sitting out here
with shaky knees and high hearts the
nominees for the best achievement in
directing our Hamlet J Arthur rank Two
Cities film universal international
British Laurence Olivier Johnny Belinda
Warner Brothers Jean Nicolet Co the
search praising of film
metro-goldwyn-mayer swiss fred cinnamon
the snake pit 20 Century Fox Anatole let
their treasures Sierra Madra Warner
Brothers John Huston again John Huston
if this were hollow and had a drink in
it I'd toast Henry blankie
thank you very much right